all right Jersey
your mom recently did an interview which
I posted a few weeks ago probably at
this point you've been separated from
your mom for a while
um I got taken
um when I was like 10 so like eight
years how old do you know I'm 18. I'm 19
now you're 19. yes
I'm 19. tell me what your childhood was
like without your mom
um
well it was weird how was it before she
left before she left
um while I was with her yes it was kind
of hard because I had a little sister
and she would take off to methadone
clinics and I would have to watch her
it's kind of why I got taken but
um it was kind of sad living with her I
loved her I mean I love her still but it
was kind of sad having to like check on
her and I had to bust in a door the
bathroom door because she like overdosed
and had a seizure
um
but and her boyfriend they did it
together and I would find um you know
the stuff on
top of the bathroom
I would I got mad at her I would say why
would you do this why would you do this
and
um she just said you wouldn't get it and
you know I didn't get it so did you do
you get it now I get it now but it's not
like she doesn't want to quit she
she she wants to quit but she wants to
quit but she can't it's hard and yeah I
I have some family members that do
Fentanyl too and they said it's really
hard to get off yeah people have done it
yeah and every once in a while somebody
breaks free but
it's a very difficult drug to quit yeah
it's really hard to get off I think
after 10 you were raised by who after 10
I went to a foster home for two years
um they treated me like I don't know
some kind of freaking animal because I
was like the only white girl and it was
like all Mexican
um and then after that I went to my knit
my grandma's my mom's mom and me and me
and her get along like my mom and her
mom like we fight we fight so I got
taken from there
and then I went to my sisters and I had
to leave because her boyfriend broke
into the house and
then I left and then I started
self-sabotaging myself because I was
like going from Foster on the fosterone
and they said oh you're like they would
give me seven day notices to leave and
um then I went to Florida
and this Christian family like I don't
know they they just forced me into it
and um then I left Florida of course you
ended up following their religion I I
kind of went along with it because they
would give me privileges like my phone
back I I didn't get my phone until I was
like 18. and I um
I left because we got in a fight I left
from Florida I walked to McDonald's like
three miles in the rain and my manager
bought my plane ticket and then I came
over here and saw my mom and it was
weird because I never seen her outside
of like DCFS supervision
so it was kind of weird
um every time I see her she like looks
skinnier and it's kind of hard because
when I hug her it's like um
I don't know
um sorry it's okay
um
it's kind of like I don't know
um I'm hugging like a different person
every time
um
but
I love her she's like this she's like
the same person still but she looks she
just looks hella different
but she has like a heart of gold and
she's like
the best person your mom seems like a
really sweet lady yeah she
everybody judges her I'm like
she would take a bullet for you even
though she doesn't know you like
she she
helps people like around here and
like she cares more about other people
and she cares about herself
so I think that makes her a pretty a
genuine person I think it helps to
understand that maybe she went through
something
difficult that she's trying to do I know
she went through like really hard times
in her life
I saw the interview I watched it I was
like some of that that she said I'm
like I didn't know you went through that
but
um
yeah then I came down here
when I was with my boyfriend and then
he's hella controlling but
um I was with him for eight years I met
him in my first foster home
and eight years eight years I know I was
amazing 10 years old well he wasn't my
boyfriend but um we kind of like grew on
each other
and you saw my boyfriend to the day but
nobody likes him but it's like hard for
me because I'm like now I get to go to
this place I get to see my mom I get to
see him and like everybody's pulling me
in directions I'm like
I don't know who are you staying with
now I'm staying with my sister in
Sacramento
yeah he was down here visiting your mom
yeah it was her birthday yesterday
yeah we got a hotel room
it was nice
but as all this taught you about how to
handle your life like seeing all the
drug addiction that's in your family
um or drugs something you've ever played
around with no I I don't do drugs I only
smoke weed
um but like most of my family does drugs
and I just kind of thought it was like
normal but I'm not used to people like
dozing out in front of me it gives me
like I don't know PTSD from my mom being
locked in the bathroom
um but
um I kind of like understand why people
do it now I don't really I don't judge
people
as I did because I was small they kind
of scared me
um
but I kind of now being like in Skid Row
seeing what my mom's doing and stuff
working with like sidewalk projects you
know
um I think it's pretty cool what she's
doing
so
it's pretty cool
um
what are you trying to do with your life
do you have goals
I don't really have any goals right now
I don't know what I'm doing yeah
graduate high school I didn't graduate
high school I um I got kicked out my dad
um got me expelled he made a terrorist
threat to my school
so I had to get kicked out and then I
got kicked out of my other Christian
School
and I didn't finish so
I have to get my GED
my mom's gonna help me get my GED
so
yeah
it's hard without a stable
yeah set of parents
yeah my dad is in Alaska I never see I
only I think I only seen him on my
second birthday
he's like a really bad drug addict he's
schizophrenic he has like
the most like I think he's high level
schizophrenia
and I don't know I was just like oh I
got dealt with the wrong cards but you
know I can't really
do anything about that but my mom's
there for me
and I mean that's the only thing that
matters really I think it's important
for you to be there for you yeah so that
you don't let yourself just become a
victim because
everyone around you is
falling through the cracks yeah
yeah I hate being the victim I never I
never want to be the Venom I'm like
I always try to like
I don't know make my story make me
stronger I guess
I'm a pretty strong person I I don't
really show feelings a lot I don't cry a
lot so that was kind of weird for me but
um yeah
yeah I don't really know what else to
say
you've been through a tough
childhood but now you're becoming an
adult
yeah being an adult's pretty scary
though
yeah I'm not even almost there but
I don't know I kind of got a taste of it
when like my boyfriend and me got a
little apartment and we couldn't pay the
rent on time so we got kicked out and
then we had to come here to Skid Row to
find like a hotel for the night
and that was pretty scary because I
didn't know where I was gonna end up
so it's a terrible place to come for a
hotel for the night yeah yeah I don't
know my boyfriend doesn't like to come
down here but I'm like you know my mom's
down here it's like kind of feels like
home wherever she is
so I feel more safer when she's with me
yeah she's still your mom yeah she's
still my mom she's always gonna be my
mom I love her
she's the funniest she's like the
coolest person
are you working now
I had a a job interview at McDonald's
but they were kind of rude to me so I
was like it's okay I'm just gonna apply
somewhere else
and I might want to work at the Pantages
here
that's pretty cool
I would want to work there
but
um yeah doing things to keep yourself
busy finding something that you love to
do would be great
focusing on that instead of letting
yourself slide it through the cracks
like yeah a lot of people down here are
doing
I might want to
look into if there's like a harm
reduction by where I live so I could
like volunteer there maybe
because I did some stuff over here I
liked it I liked um the feeling of
helping people it's great it's pretty
cool
I'm sure you can relate to everyone's
stories yeah and it feels good because
like you know that could be somebody
else's mom that you're helping
I always think about that like you know
she might have a relationship with her
kid too no
she gets better
do you see any of the self-destructive
traits that you see
in your family in yourself
yes I like self-sabotaged myself all the
time it's like I get bored of something
and I just like need to
like excitement or something
that's what I used to do in my foster
homes I would get kicked out on purpose
I don't know why I did it but I was just
bored and I was tired of being in
classrooms fosterone so sure yeah got
tiring
and
yeah the system sucks
what's your biggest fear right now my
biggest fear is probably losing her
because you know just playing around
with A Dangerous Drug
yeah she's playing around with the
Dangerous Drug and
she has a lot of house problems so
I don't know those two don't mix well
no and she it's hard because she said
she does it to like help with the pain
but it's only making it worse but
I can't tell her anything you know she's
an adult
but she's trying she's going to get
medicine to get off the drugs hopefully
and then she's gonna get a house seen I
might move in with her my I'm I will
move in with her
and
then she wants to get a little animal
shelter she wants to own one so
maybe that's in the future
I look forward to it
there any lessons that you've learned
yet in life that are valuable lessons
that I learned
don't lie don't lie about everything I
had a problem with that I would lie
about the simplest stuff
and probably
I don't know don't
don't trust people too much
because I don't know I think I'm
I
look for like companionship and
everybody I don't know but
I'm I wouldn't say I haven't maybe I do
but I don't think I have abandonment
issues
maybe I do because I cling on to a lot
of people that I feel close to
um
yeah but
I learned to not trust people all the
way so
their intentions aren't good sometimes
all right Jersey thank you so much for
coming in and talking yeah your life and
your mom's I wish you all the luck in
the world
thank you you deserve it you too thank
you very much okay